♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
ELON MUSK CAME FAMOUS AS A
BUSINESSMAN.
HE MAKES ELECTRIC CARS AND
ROCKETS IT HAS BECOME THE SINGLE
RICHEST PERSON ON PLANET EARTH
BY DOING THAT.
ELON MUSK IS NOT FROM THE
UNITED STATES, HE GREW UP IN
SOUTH AFRICA, AND GET HE HAS A
KEEN AND PRECISE UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW OUR SYSTEM WAS DESIGNED
TO WORK.
AS HE PUT IT ON TWITTER LAST
MONTH, "FREE SPEECH IS ESSENTIAL
TO A FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY."
AND THEN MUSK ASKED HIS
80 MILLION FOLLOWERS ON TWITTER
THIS QUESTION.
"DO YOU BELIEVE TWITTER IT
REGULARLY AND HERE'S TO THE
PRINCIPAL"?
AND OVERWHELMINGLY THEY ANSWERED
NO, IT DOESN'T.
SO ELON MUSK UNDERSTANDS
SOMETHING ABOUT TWITTER THAT
MANY PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY DON'T
UNDERSTAND, IT IS THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT FORM FOR SPEECH
POSSIBLY IN THE WORLD.
NOT BECAUSE IT'S THE BIGGEST,
BUT BECAUSE IT'S WHERE ELITE
OPINION IS INCUBATED.
AND SO FREE SPEECH ON TWITTER
MATTERS, AND LAST MONTH,
ELON MUSK GAVE THE IMPRESSION
THAT HE PLANNED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT, THAT HE PLANNED TO
OPEN UP TWITTER, HE BOUGHT 10%
OF THE COMPANY.
NOW, TODAY, MUSK HAS JUST PUT AN
OFFER TO BUY 100% OF TWITTER AT
$54 A SHARE AND TAKE THE COMPANY
PRIVATE.
NOW, FROM A BUSINESS
PERSPECTIVE, THIS IS A VERY
TEMPTING OFFER FOR THE COMPANY.
IN FACT, HIS OPERA PRISONS A 54%
PREMIUM OVER THE COMPANY'S SHARE
PRICE THE DAY BEFORE HE BEGAN
INVESTING IN IT.
HE WROTE A LETTER TO TWITTER'S
BOARD LAST NIGHT.
"TWITTER HAS EXTORTED OUR
POTENTIAL, I WILL UNLOCK IT."
SO THIS IS MORE THAN A BUSINESS
PLAY.
IN FACT, IT'S NOT AN
OVERSTATEMENT TO SAY COULD BE
THE MOST IMPORTANT DEVELOPMENT
FOR FREE SPEECH IN THE MODERN
HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES.
AS MUSK PUT IT, TWITTER'S
POTENTIAL IS TO BE "THE PLATFORM
FOR FREE SPEECH AROUND THE
GLOBE."
TWITTER WILL "NEITHER THRIVE NOR
SERVE THE SOCIETAL IMPERATIVE IN
ITS CURRENT FORM."
TWITTER NEEDS TO BE TRANSFORMED
AS A PRIVATE COMPANY.
MUSK THEN MADE IT CLEAR HE HAS
NO CONFIDENCE WHATSOEVER THE
PEOPLE CURRENTLY RUN TWITTER,
INCLUDING ITS PRO-CENSORSHIP
CEO -- "IF THIS DEAL DOESN'T
WORK, GIVEN I HAVE NO CONFIDENCE
IN MANAGEMENT OR DRIVE THE
NECESSARY CHANGE OF THE PUBLIC
MARKET, I WOULD NEED TO
RECONSIDER MY POSITION AS A
SHAREHOLDER."
THAT MEANS IF TWITTER'S BOARD
REJECTS ELON MUSK'S OFFER, THEY
WILL NEED TO EXPLAIN WHY TO
THEIR SHAREHOLDERS THEY TURNED
OUT A DEAL THAT WOULD MAKE THE
SHAREHOLDERS MUCH RICHER.
SO BY DOING THIS, ELON MUSK IS
PUTTING EVERYTHING ON THE LINE.
HE KNOWS HOW IMPORTANT TWITTER
IS TO THE PEOPLE WHO RUN OUR
SYSTEM, WHO RUN THE GLOBAL
SYSTEM.
FOR THEM, CENSORSHIP AND
PROPAGANDA IS NOT A FEATURE OF
THEIR RULE.
THEIR RULE DEPENDS ON CENSORSHIP
AND PROPAGANDA.
IF YOU ARE OFFERING POLICIES
THAT REALLY BENEFIT NOBODY BUT
YOURSELF, YOU HAVE TO LIE ABOUT
THEM, AND YOU MUST PREVENT
ANYONE FROM COMPLAINING ABOUT
IT.
SO CENSORSHIP AND PROPAGANDA ARE
AT THE VERY HEART OF
NEOLIBERALISM, AND ELON MUSK IS
CHALLENGING ALL OF THAT
DIRECTLY.
HE'S THE RICHEST MEN IN THE
WORLD, HE'S NOT TRYING TO MAKE
MORE MONEY, HE'S NOT DONATING TO
A FOREIGN CHARITY OR CRATING A
TAX SHELTER.
IN THIS CASE HE'S USING HIS
MONEY TO ALLOW AT LEAST
POTENTIALLY AMERICANS TO SPEAK
FREELY.
IS IT DISTRESSING THAT OUR OWN
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM ISN'T WORKING,
THAT YOU WOULD NEED SOME RICH
GUY TO SWOOP IN DEUS EX MACHINA
FREE-SPEECH UNITED STATES
STATES?
OF COURSE IT IS.
IS IT SAD THAT WHERE WAITING FOR
ELON MUSK TO SAVE US?
YES, IT IS, BUT WHO ELSE WAS
GOING TO SAVE US?
NOBODY AT THIS POINT.
SO OF COURSE CORPORATE MEDIA,
WHICH EXISTS TO STIFLE THE VIEWS
OF INDIVIDUAL AMERICANS, HATES
THE IDEA, AND THEIR FIRST MOVE
IS TO MOCK IT.
WATCH.
>> HE SAYS HE WANTS TO PAY
$54.20 A SHARE TO BUY UP THE
REST OF TWITTER THAT HE DOESN'T
HAVE.
OF COURSE 54.20, A CODE FOR
MARIJUANA, WHICH HE VERY MUCH
ENJOYS.
IS THIS ALL A TROLL OR IS IT
VERY REAL?
>> IT'S BAZAAR.
>> THE 420 CODING AND
EVERYTHING.
>> THIS IS MY LAST AND FINAL
OFFER, NOT GOING TO NEGOTIATE.
>> Tucker: IT CAN'T REALLY BE
REAL.
WELL, THINK IT THROUGH FOR A
SECOND.
BY CHALLENGING THE MONOPOLY ON
SPEECH, NOT JUST THE
UNITED STATES, BUT GLOBALLY,
ON TWITTER, ON THIS CENTRAL
PLATFORM FOR IDEAS, ELON MUSK IS
RISKING EVERYTHING THAT HE HAS.
HE HAS MANY BUSINESSES THAT
INTERSECT WITH GOVERNMENTS
AROUND THE WORLD.
THEY ARE NOT FOR THIS, THEY
COULD CRUSH THEM FOR EVEN
SUGGESTING IT.
SO HE'S ALL IN, HE HAS TO BE ALL
IN.
EVEN TO SAY SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
AT TWITTER, THEY KNOW HE'S ALL
IN AND THAT'S WHY THEY ARE SO
UPSET ABOUT IT.
ACCORDING TO A BLOOMBERG REPORT,
EVEN BEFORE MUSK'S OFFER OF A
HOSTILE TAKEOVER, "THE VIBE
AMONG WORKERS AT TWITTER IS
"SUPER STRESSED" WITH EMPLOYEES
"WORKING TOGETHER TO HELP EACH
OTHER GET THROUGH THE WEEK"."
THAT'S HOW THREATENING THIS IS.
AND YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF,
WHAT KIND OF COMPANY'S TWITTER?
THE COMPANY'S STOCK JUST JUMPED
30%, THAT HAPPENED WHEN
ELON MUSK FIRST BOUGHT IN.
SO OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT A
COMPANY THAT EXISTS TO MAKE
MONEY, THIS IS A COMPANY THAT
EXISTS TO CENSOR SPEECH.
THAT'S A TALL PURPOSE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CERTAINLY UNDERSTANDS THIS AND
THEY'VE ALREADY MADE A MOVE TO
INTIMIDATE MUSK INTO BACKING
OFF.
FOX BUSINESS OF ASTERISK
CHARLIE GASPARINO WAS REPORTING
THAT "AS ELON MUSK OFFERS TO BUY
THE REST OF TWITTER, A LEGAL
SOURCE TELLS FOX BUSINESS THAT
THE SEC AND THE DOJ HAVE
LAUNCHED WHAT HE DESCRIBED AS A
JOINT INVESTIGATION INTO A
MYRIAD OF MUSK REGULATORY
ISSUES, PRIMARILY INVOLVING
TESLA."
IN OTHER WORDS, THREATEN TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO SPEAK FREELY AND
WE WILL CRUSH YOUR BUSINESSES.
THAT'S THIRD WORLD BEHAVIOR.
AT "THE WASHINGTON POST," OWNED
BY ALSO ONE OF THE RICHEST
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD, VERY MUCH
SUPPORTS STOPPING EVEN MUSK.
IN FACT HE TELLS US HE MUST BE
SILENCED IN THE NAME OF
DEMOCRACY.
"I'M FRIGHTENED OF THE IMPACT ON
SOCIETY AND POLITICS AT
ELON MUSK ACQUIRES TWITTER.
HE SEEMS TO BELIEVE THAT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA ANYTHING GOES.
FOR DEMOCRACY TO SURVIVE, WE
NEED MORE CONTENT MODERATION,
NOT LESS."
REALLY?
SO FOR DEMOCRACY TO SURVIVE,
CITIZENS AND THE DEMOCRACY NEED
TO TALK LESS, NEED TO EXPRESS
THEIR OPINIONS MORE GUARDEDLY,
NEED TO SHUT UP?
WHAT KIND OF DEMOCRACY ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT?
IT'S NOT DEMOCRACY AS THE
ATHENIANS ARE THE FOUNDERS OF
THIS COUNTRY UNDERSTOOD IT.
DEMOCRACY IS A EUPHEMISM FOR
LETTING OUR MAFIA RUN YOUR
COUNTRY, FOR OUR BENEFIT.
JOURNALISM PROFESSOR CALLED JEFF
JARVIS EXPLAINED TODAY
ON TWITTER THAT TYRANNY IS WHEN
THE REGIME CAN'T CENSOR ITS OWN
CITIZENS.
"TODAY ON TWITTER FEELS LIKE THE
LAST EVENING IN A BERLIN
NIGHTCLUB AT THE TOILET OF THE
WEIMAR GERMANY.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU'RE A NAZI IF
YOU ARE SPEAKING FREELY
ON TWITTER.
CNBC HOST JOE KIERNAN
UNDERSTANDS EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
ON.
IF TWITTER IS OPENED UP, THAT
MEANS PEOPLE WHO ARE PAID TO
CENSOR THE PUBLIC ON TWITTER
WILL LOSE THEIR ABILITY, THEY
WILL LOSE THEIR GUARDIANSHIP OF
FREE SPEECH.
WATCH THIS.
>> WHO IS THAT ADL GUY?
THIS IS HIS WORST NIGHTMARE.
I THINK JONATHAN GREENBLATT.
IF HE OWNS THE WHOLE PLACE, IT'S
GOING TO BE LIKE GO FOR IT.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE AN
ORANGE MAN PROBABLY GOING TO BE
BACK IN THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Tucker: HE'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
AGAIN, YOU CAN'T OVERSTATE WHAT
A THREAT THIS IS NOT SIMPLY TO
THE PEOPLE OCCUPYING SEATS OF
POLITICAL POWER, BUT TO THE
WHOLE NONPROFIT UNIVERSE THAT
EXISTS AND THRIVES AND BECOMES
RICH SUPPORTING THEM THROUGH
CENSORSHIP AND PROPAGANDA.
SO A GROUP LIKE THE ADL OR MEDIA
MATTERS TAKE MONEY IN ORDER TO
CENSOR PEOPLE.
THE ISSUE SOME REPORT CALLING
YOU A RACIST AND THEN
SOCIAL MEDIA SHUT YOU DOWN.
ELON MUSK IS SAYING NO, PEOPLE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SPEAK FREELY.
THAT WOULD MEAN THE END OF THEIR
CONTROL OVER SPEECH.
JUST LIKE THE ADL AND MEDIA
MATTERS.
SO THE MEDIA AND THESE NONPROFIT
GROUPS HAVE TO STOP THIS BEFORE
IT HAPPENS.
HERE'S MSNBC TELLING YOU THAT
ELON MUSK MUST BE STOPPED
BECAUSE HE'S A BIGOT.
>> HE'S ONE OF THE MOST
THIN-SKINNED PEOPLE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
INITIAL HEAT TRIED TO COMFORT
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN, WHO
TWEETED LET'S CHANGE THE TAX
CODE SO THAT THE PERSON OF THE
YEAR WILL ACTUALLY PAY TAXES AND
STOP FREELOADING OFF EVERYONE
ELSE.
ELON WASN'T HAPPY.
HE DID WHAT HE ALWAYS DID AND
SENT INSULTS TO ENTER TO WARRANT
CALLING HER AN ANGRY MOM AND
REFERRING TO HER AS
SENATOR KAREN.
SO FOR SO MANY REASONS, BEING A
FREELOADER AND A SELFISH AND
DISRESPECTFUL ONE, AND FOR
MISAPPROPRIATING BLACK
VERNACULAR FOR MISOGYNISTIC
PURPOSES, ELON MUSK IS THE
ABSOLUTE WORST.
>> Tucker: SO ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE POLITICAL PARTY THAT
SUPPORTED ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY BY
OLIGARCHS LIKE JEFF BEZOS AND
GOOGLE GUYS IS TELLING YOU THAT
IT'S DANGEROUS FOR RICH PEOPLE
TO HAVE TOO MUCH CONTROL OVER
SPEECH.
REALLY?
FACEBOOK IS CONTROLLED BY ONE
PERSON, MARK ZUCKERBERG, BUT
THAT'S NOT A THREAT BECAUSE
MARK ZUCKERBERG IS HAPPY TO WORK
ON BEHALF OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
ONCE AGAIN, IF ANYTHING, WE ARE
UNDERSTATING WHAT A BIG DEAL
THIS MOVE ON TWITTER BUT YOU ON
MUSK IS.
IF FREE SPEECH IS